?
Y
THEORISTY RERT TAL RLD VIOLENCE.
HETRTIMERESULTBEUG CLAIM THAP
ARIZON
WIONT OF IKEF INSURRECTI
REVEALED AND SOME WILLAN.
CTION AUDIT IS
ENTERING THE FINAL
2.1 MILLBAS EXAMINED BY
UE OONLYUNT BUPR
BIZARRETIFROM THE
THE LA CERSY-F
AUDIT SERVERS
POTENTIALLY
F VOTERS.A
REPUBLICANS SAY  HAVE HAD
OF TG TH
THEEST BELIEVE ITL CE ANYONO I
WAR  ELECTION
WAERVATIVE TALSHOWT KEBROOMHEAD.
YOU FIRST SUPPORTETHDIT W AI
WHY HAS YOUR POSITION CHGE
>> I THAT THEY LT FOCUS
IASSED AUDITAKING TOLE THA
OF TIME THE ELONAND NOPRODUCED O
RY BUT RELEASED ON SOCIA OF DIVN
LEGITIMATE TULD BE GOOD TO REASE
WHO HAESTIONS.
RIGHT?
ID
ID                            D
PEOPLE IE AUDIT SO THESE
OP KNOD
MA CASES.
I JUST THA
THATACVOTERS I
A HUGE DEMOGIC
CONCEN E DON'
CONCERN THAN THERE IS I GUESS
DOINLICANING THAN ITH IN 'S HAP.
OUTRAGED.
KNOW.NA IS SOMEI REA GREAT HAT
FRUSTRATME.
THOS WSEEN IS CATERINGO TH
ATVE IT'S HAPPENED ANDE  DANGE
NEED TO BE CONVINCING PEOPLE
INSTEAD OFT PREAING TO THE
CHTHE
TION FOR THE AUDIT
ALL TRA VIOLE
CHASE DOWN THEY  CIRTI ONLINBYD
CONSPIRACY THEORIES GAIN TOO N ?
E XAEXAMPLE THAT I USEIS
CHASING  BAMIN
OF CLINT HICKMANE FAMIUSS IN
IZA AND A HUGE FIRE
ACCUSED EDINCHBALLOTAN BURNI
BARNS KILLIN0 CHICKED CLINT HIC
CHASE RU CHASE
DOWN THAT CONSPIRACY
WHAT M
HAPPEN>> WHYE BALLOTS?IT THINGS
THN'RSTAND.
HELP US UNDEYOU TWO-TIME TRUMP.
E PI R
THINK THIS IS WHERE YOU
THOIR.
SUPPORTIVE, THE PEOPLE THAT --IT
POLITI IUE OTHHET ARE THE ES BET
E ANO  ABOUT.
WEAVRACE
D  LOOKING
FORWARD TO WNI THE
PEOPLAS
BIG FRUSTRA. T  O
YOU STAND FRE FACT HES
AUDIT, A NSTING
Y
SUPPORTING THETITUTI
THE CHAOSW.HERE'S THE THING SET
IN
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT PEI WO ARR
E SERVATIVES
LE E CHARACTER IS CALLE
AU TY DARE SAY
AV THENGT TH AND
CONCERNS THAT ALS R
AG
ONLY B TO
COUNTRY?
>> MY CONCERN -- I
SO.
I DON'T -- I DON'T WANT TO CAL
PEOPLE VIOLENT BECAUHEY AR
LI.Y PEOPLE THABE
THEIR
I E
ACTIONPE THE
ATWHAT TS O DO IS IN ONWECS.
WLEN  202STR.HEY DON'T WANT ATH
NOOLENCE.
>>YOU COMING HONESVIEW
ABOUT THIS AND ABSY